بدا العد التنازلي لاسدال الستار على
المونديال ولازال القطريون يكتشفون بحماس
حقائق اكثر عن اكبر حدث رياضي يجري على
اراضيهم منذ اليوم الاول من المونديال
فقدت الدوحه هدوءها النسبي فكل الفضاءات
باتت مزدحمه ليلا ونهارا وهو ما نال
استحسان الكثير من القطريين بعضهم بات
يتمنى لو ان المونديال يمدد العدد همم
اللي توقعناه جاء اكثر منه والحمد لله
والبلد تشيل همم الامور طيبه ونقدر
نتعايش معهم الكل ونرحب بهم الجميع
بس انه المشكله ان الحدث فتره معينه يعني
ويا ليتنا للفتره اطول على اساس نقدر
نستضيفهم اكثر
تكيف السكان هنا بسرعه مع مختلف الجنسيات
التي تدفقت عليهم التعايش مع الزائرين بدد
بسرعه الاسئله التي طرحت حول استقبالهم
وبشان حريتهم في عين المكانز بريكه
انا سعيد جدا والشعب هنا ودود ومرحب
التنظيم جيد كل شيء رائع لم اشعر بالغربه
في البلد طوال وجودهم هنا
شوارع الدوحه وتهم الملاعب الموندياليه
ومناطق المشجعين كانت فضاءات للحوار دون
حدود بعض المشجعين كانوا متخوفنا قبل
الوصول لكن تبين لهم ان تلك المخاوف بنيت
على احكام مسبقه غداتها بعض وسائل الاعلام
الاوروبيه فاحنا وفاتحين على العالم
الخارجي واحنا شعب معروف بالترحال
والسفر
فكان الروح نزور العالم كلها حين العالم
جاءنا الى حد بيتنا
فاحنا شعب بطبيعته كثير في السياسه همم
الثقافيه لدوله قطر هو الانفتاح على
العالم الخارجي واحنا نؤمن ان التنوع هو
مصدر قوه
عندما تتفاعل اصداء وترددات المونديال
الخارجه المستطيل الاخضر يتضح للجميع ان
كره القدم هي اكثر من مجرد رياضه وهذا
الذي تجسده هنا باقامه جسر للتلاقي بين
السكان هذا البلد وبين الاجانب جسر
للتفاهم مع الاخر بعيدا عن الاحكام
النبطيه نور الدين الجزيره الدوحه